[موسيقى]
هناك هوس في سياتل
للسطور وسوف يقودونك إلى
القهوة،
وباعتباري أحد محبي القهوة، فهذا هوس
سأستمتع به بحرية إذا
أتيت إلى هنا كثيرًا، نعم ابقني هنا حسنًا،
ممتاز
ستاربكس، عالم نحل القهوة العالمي
بدأت هنا وعلى الرغم من أن حاضرها
منتشر في كل مكان، إلا أنه لم يمنع العشرات من
المنافسين الأصغر حجمًا من
فتح الكابتشينو وازدهاره، من فضلك،
هذه سرية حقيقية، أحبها
[موسيقى]
حسنًا، إذا كنا سنصنع  12 أونصة
لاتيه، ها نحن ذا، سوف تتذكر أن
تخمير الإسبريسو وفن اللاتيه كانا من
مشاريعي الوبائية، أنا جيد في الأول
وسيء في الثانية، خطوتنا الأولى في
التحضير هي أنك تريد تحضير
الحليب، يمتلك داني كوهن هذا المتجر العام
و  على وشك أن تصبح مرشدتي على
الفور، في البداية أدخل القليل من الهواء، هل يمكنها أن
تجعلني أخيرًا أرسم بشكل صحيح على
الكريما، أشير إلى أخطائي لأنني أمر بها، حسنًا،
جاهز لواحدة
هيا أولاً، نريد تحضير
الحليب  أوه نعم، نعم، لم يستغرق الأمر وقتًا طويلاً، هل
فعلت ذلك، نعم، حسنًا، أنت جاهز، أعني أنه
يمكنك القيام بذلك، فقط أطعم ذلك، نعم، أفهم
تمامًا افتتان داني بالقهوة،
سنذهب بشكل رائع، لقد حصلت على هذا، لقد حصلت على
هذا، لا استمر في الصب، استمر في
الصب، استمر في السكب  استمر في صب الماء،
ولم تكن تبدو رائعًا، هكذا
وقعت في حب صناعة القهوة
عندما كان عمري 15 عامًا وحصلت على أول وظيفة لي في باريستا،
لأنه كان ذلك المكان الذي
وجدته أيضًا مكانًا آتي إليه حيث يكون
شخص ما سعيدًا برؤيته
الإذن الصحيح للانطلاق
والركض
هنا لدينا حب للقهوة
وإحساس بالمكان تحول إلى مهنة، لذا
سأبدأ الأمر بهذه الزاوية
عندما افتتحت داني مقاهيها
والآن أسلوبها الحديث في المتجر العام
الذي يحتوي على قهوة  شريط بالطبع إنه في
الدم إنه في الدم نعم لا أستطيع ألا
أفعل ذلك ولقد أحببت دائمًا
المتاجر العامة حتى قبل أن أعرف أنها كانت في عائلتنا
وهي تتحدث عن
جدها الأكبر الذي شق طريقه إلى
سياتل  افتتحت أوائل القرن العشرين أيضًا
متجرًا عامًا مخروطيًا وستاينر وقد
أعادت النظر فيه من خلال تسمية
متجرها العام الجديد CNS
Danny's ولم أتفق معي ولكن هناك
درسًا آخر تريد نقله لذلك
نريد أن نأخذك إلى الموقع الأصلي  كونان
ستاينر لجدي الأكبر في أوائل القرن العشرين وهذا
عنوان يعرفه الكثير من الناس لأنك
ربما سمعت عن هذه
الشركة المحلية وهذا هو مقرها الرئيسي،
فأنت تخبرني أن
المتجر الأصلي لجدك الأكبر والذي منه
المقهى هو السلالة،
نعم
هنا
لست متأكدًا مما إذا كانت هذه مفارقة أم
عدالة شعرية، أعلم أنني أعلم أنه
نجاح غير متوقع لا يصدق
في المقهى الذي يصل إلي
أيضًا أخيرًا، فلنفعل هذا نعم، هناك،
إنه هناك  لقد عادوا
بهذه الطريقة سوف يأتون إلى هنا هنا
استمروا
انظروا إلى هذا
نعم
هذا رائع
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لك